an increased army presence on the
streets in el salvador an immediate
reaction to a bloody weekend 62
homicides on saturday the most in one
single day in more than 20 years
the president and congress passing a
temporary move to impose restrictions on
assembly extend police detentions and
allow the intercept of communications
like phone calls
the decree that declares the emergency
regime is approved
el salvador is home to several violent
gangs while president native buchelli
has been credited with cutting the crime
rate it's still one of the most violent
countries on earth he tweeted his
approval of the assembly's endorsement
of his move saying the measures to be
taken will be implemented by the
pertinent institutions and announced
only when it's necessary for the
majority of the population life
continues as normal may god bless us all
many on the streets of san salvador
backed the move
i think it's good because it's excellent
if we can look out for each other let
him show he is against crime that's all
i can say
i think the approval is good because
there's too much violence and injustice
happening everything had calmed down but
this is revenge against the government
if it was in my hands i would give them
a harsh penalty as they say a brutal
punishment
president because previously been
accused of negotiating a truce with the
gangs to win their political support
something he denies
the new restrictions are in place for 30
days
but could be extended alan fisher al
jazeera